الاطباق على خانيونس هو ما يسعى الجيش
الاسرائيلي اليه منذ ايام وفق ما يصل من
اخبار الميدان يبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
في مراحله الاخيره لعزل خان يونس عن
محافظات وسط القطاع شمالا وفصلها تماما عن
محافظه رفح جنوبا وبالتالي يستفرد بما
يصفه معقلا رئيسيا لقاده القسام تحاصر
الدبابات الاسرائيليه مستشفى الامل
التابعه للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني والواقعه
غربيه مدينه خانيونس في الوقت ذاته تواصل
القوات الاسرائيليه محاولاتها للتقدم من
مناطق جنوب المحافظه الى مناطق اقصى الغرب
في الخامس من ديسمبر الماضي بدا الجيش
الاسرائيلي اجتياحه البر لخان يونس بدات
المعركه البريه بتوغل الدبابات
الاسرائيليه من معسكر كيسوفيم المحاذي
لبلده القراره شمال شرق خانيونس سبقت ذلك
احزمه ناريه كثيفه على مناطق شرق القراره
من كيسوفيم الى القراره اكملت القوات
الاسرائيليه طريقها وصولا الى حاجز
المطاحن الواقع تماما على شارع صلاح الدين
ومن هناك اكملت الاليات الاسرائيليه
توغلها عبر مناطق زراعيه مفتوحه حتى وصلت
الى شارع الرشيد على ساحل البحر حيث فصلت
الاليات الاسرائيليه خانيونس من جهه
الشمال عن مناطق وسط القطاع بعد 50 يوما
من بد اجتياحها البري تصل الاليات
الاسرائيليه لمحيط مستشفى الامل الغربيه
خانيونس وم مستشفى ناصر المستشفى الرئيسي
هناك اما في شرق خان يونس فلم تهدا
الاشتباكات والقصف المدفعي بعد نحو شهرين
من القتال كانت بني سهيله النقطه الثانيه
للتوغل البري وتحديدا من منطقه الفخاري
حيث دخلت الاليات الاسرائيليه تحت غطاء
ناري كثيف واحزمه ناريه حرقت كل شيء
واكملت مسيرها حتى وصلت الى بني سهيله
كذلك توغلت قوات اسرائيليه من منطقه الزنه
ومن جهه عبسان الجديد حتى فصلت مناطق شرق
خانيونس تماما عن مناطق غرب المحافظه وبعد
فصل خانيونس عن وسط القطاع وعزل الشرقي
المحافظه عن غربها تتحرك القوات
الاسرائيليه لفصل خانيونس تماما عن رفح
تتبع اسرائيل في ذلك السيناريو مشابها لما
حدث في
2014 حيث تتحرك الاليات الاسرائيليه من
منطقه صوفا والفخار جنوب شرق خانيونس
وتحاول التوغل نحو المنطقه الغربيه وصولا
الى شارع الرشيد على ساحل البحر وبذلك
تقطع وتفصل خانيونس تماما من الجنوب
وتفصلها كليا عن رفح يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه في خانيونس يقاتل فوق
الارض وتحتها ويبدو انه متفاجئ من شراسه
المقاومه في محاور القتال هناك هذا ما
يكشفه رئيس الاركان هيرسي هاليفي بقوله
انهم يحاربون عدوا كان يستعد لفتره طويله
جدا للدفاع عن نفسه بطريقه منظمه جدا وان
القتال يدور في منطقه جغرافيه معقده
للغايه